Inexact repeating alarms.
Infinitely better than
exact repeating alarms,
but still far from ideal.
The problem with any kind
of repeating alarm
is that it's still polling
your server to check for updates.
So the more frequently you poll,
the fresher the data you can display
but the higher the cost in battery life.
You can pull as frequently
to conserve battery
but that just means
your content will be stale
for longer.
You could just let the user decide
the update frequency themselves,
but then you lose the magic.
If only there was a better way.
Is such a thing possible?
Yes it is.
Google cloud messaging
let's your server notify your app
directly when there's data ready
to be downloaded.
Or it can even
include the new data
in the message payload itself.
Using Google Cloud Messaging,
you can send messages from
your server to any installed instance
of your app via the Google Cloud.
As a result, you can stop polling,
which will immediately
improve battery life
and also improve
the freshness of your app.
And instead, rely on your server
notifying clients when
there's data to sync.
These messages can be simple tickles,
that trigger a sync adapter
by notifying your app
that there is new data
or need to download.
Or you can include the new data
within the message payload.
In the sunshine example,
we're using someone else's server.
But even then,
it may make sense to create
your own middle tier
that pulls the source
and notifies your installed app instances
when it notices a change.
Now we're not going to set up
a server in this lesson,
but you can see the full details
for using Google cloud messaging
from the developer guide
linked to instructor nets.